young boys are basically faced with a
new form of sexual politics which treats
them as though they're inherently
dangerous to girls and young women that
treats them as though they basically
can't control their instincts and we see
this in adverts on the tube there are
signs that say uh unwanted staring is
sexual harassment and that kind of thing
but there are also these groups going
into schools that are talking to young
boys and they're saying uh basically
masculinity is something that needs to
be changed and they're saying again we
need to stop violence against women and
girls all things that are you know
perfectly good and proper everyone
agrees with that I think the problem is
that is that in some ways the pendulum
is one
to such an extent that boys feel like
they can't express any form of
masculinity really